I'm not going to spend a ton of time on
this but because I told you about it
earlier this week I do want to follow up
earlier this week after being arrested
for a second time Donald Trump went to
the Cuban restaurant in Miami Versailles
and at that restaurant Donald Trump
promised food for everyone okay remember
this bizarre moment are you ready are
you ready
food for everyone
[Applause]
okay my immediate reaction was I'd get a
credit card up front before giving
anybody food that supposedly Trump is
going to pay for the Miami New Times can
now report that Donald Trump did not pay
for anybody's food at Versailles the
article confirms Trump opted to
decompress with a trip to Versailles in
Little Havana
Trump and his Entourage arrived there
shortly after leaving the courthouse
Trump said food for everyone so the new
times wondered did Trump treat his fan
club to some food
it turns out no one got anything not
even a cafecito to go
a knowledgeable Source assures the new
times that Trump's stop was 10 minutes
long it didn't leave time for anyone to
eat anything much less place an order
and of course Donald Trump did not leave
any instructions to Bill him or charge
his credit card or whatever the case may
be this is a very small story in the
broader context of everything that
happened in the last week which was an
absolutely insane week it is not the
most important story but it is a
reminder that this is a habitually
dishonest and Despicable guy who cares
about his supporters only as far as they
are useful to him and the Versailles
incident is the epitome of that he shows
up they're cheering they sing him happy
birthday they're praying over him the
photo op is extraordinarily useful and
so he yells out food for everyone
but then he leaves because he doesn't
actually care about it he doesn't
actually want to give anyone anything he
doesn't actually respect or value these
people anywhere beyond the extent to
which they are useful to his campaign we
saw it with the fundraising grifts we
saw it around elections we've seen it so
many times food for everyone I would
have gotten the credit card up front he
paid for nobody's food we have a
fantastic program for you today few
programming notes number one we will be
off on Monday for Juneteenth number two
then I will be here Tuesday but then
away for a wedding not my wedding I will
be on the west coast for a wedding so
after the Tuesday show for which I will
be here then we'll have some great guest
hosts I think you will enjoy it make
sure that you are subscribed to the
YouTube channel we made more progress in
this last week towards the 2 million uh
subscriber goal than we have in many
many months let's close out the week
super strong at youtube.com the
davidpackman show it's free at costs
nothing and also we are starting to put
a Republican primary debates on the
streaming calendar I know that it is
insane because it is only June we're
getting to the end of June into July of
2023 but the Republican debates are
starting the first one is scheduled for
August 23. uh it will be a Fox News
debate we are figuring out whether we
can stream it live without getting
absolutely crushed by Fox news's
copyright enforcement division
I will have news about that soon but we
will do everything we can to bring you
as much of campaign 2024 as we can let's
take a very quick break we've got a
packed program ahead of the three-day
weekend
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fumes success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save ten percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below